the white house acknowledges there may
be christmas shortages as the economy
stagnates nancy pelosi chides the media
for not selling her big spending package
and the feds go to war with florida and
texas over vaccine mandates i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here's the deal you
think that you need to be with one of
the big carriers in order for you to
have great cell phone coverage this is
untrue you could have the same exact
cell phone coverage except without
paying the big bucks you don't have to
be with verizon or tnt and t-mobile
because they're just spending all of
your money on overhead and on those
stores you never visit instead why not
switch over to pure talk usa pure talk
is not going to charge you for any of
that garbage instead they give you
killer 5g coverage on the same 5g
network as one of the big guys for about
half the cost the average family is
saving over 800 a year so what exactly
is your excuse i made the switch you can
too you can keep your number keep your
phone or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and listen if
you still want unlimited data you can
get it and save a fortune go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that is
right for you they have a 30 day risk
free guarantee so you literally have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com enter
promo code shapiro you will save 50 off
your very first month of coverage that's
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless again head on
over to puretalk.com enter promo code
shapiro and save 50 off your very first
month okay so first off if you didn't
come to the daily wire backstage last
night live at the ryman or if you didn't
watch it you missed out made a bunch of
big announcements here at daily wire
we've got a brand new show that is going
to be coming out with adam corellis
we're getting into the comedy we're
getting into the comedy game
we also premiered the trailer for our
new movie shut-in which will be out
early next year we also give you an
update from gina carano's new film that
is now filming up in montana so lots
going on here at the daily wire and we
are very excited to bring all of it to
you alrighty so here is the latest in
the news
the economy is now in a serious state of
stagnation
and joe biden apparently this is all
according to plan i mean they wanted
fundamental change in the economy this
is according to the white house they
wanted fundamental change in the economy
they're about to get fundamental change
in the economy here is jen saki the
white house press secretary saying that
joe biden's agenda is to make
fundamental change in the economy which
is strange because most people just want
to go back to work and you know have a
job and have food on the table and be
able to buy things for less than they
bought them for yesterday but apparently
not the white house
the president wants to make fundamental
change in our economy and he feels
coming out of the pandemic is exactly
the time to do that and if we don't do
it now if we don't address uh the cost
of child care to go back to josh's
question earlier if we don't uh address
the climate crisis if we don't ensure
that universal pre-k is a reality now
uh we're we're not going to have the
same opportunity to do it for some time
this is insane okay this is her saying
no good crisis goes to waste and this is
a crisis entirely of the
administration's own making at this
point because everybody should be back
to work see it is very strange how
democratic logic goes when everything is
going swimmingly now is a great time for
us to restructure everything because
everything is going swimmingly right we
got the money to do it everything is
great we should be able to do what we've
always wanted to do and pursue utopia
and then when things go poorly they're
like now is the greatest time ever for
us to restructure this economy i think
things are going so poorly i mean when
are we ever going to have the
opportunity to do this again i feel like
the first part of the sentence has
nothing to do with the second part of
the sentence it doesn't matter what the
preconditions are your solution is
always what if we just restructure the
economy in socialistic redistributionist
big government ways because that's kind
of what we want to do and we're going to
use whatever is happening right now as
the excuse the thing is the taste of the
american public for completely
restructuring the american economy is
not there the american public is not
into this stuff and they shouldn't be
into this stuff because the consequences
of joe biden's policies are already
being felt i'll be the first to admit
i was wrong i thought that joe biden was
going to have two years of sailing
economic growth because i didn't think
that even joe biden was capable of
screwing things up this bad
truly if you go back to his inauguration
i said this guy is the luckiest sob to
take the office of the presidency maybe
ever because he was taking over in the
wake of a pretty unpopular president by
the poll numbers he was taking over
having control of both the senate and
the house he was taking over with a
vaccine already ready to go already
being tranched out at a million vaccines
a day in the middle of a pandemic
expectations were low
there was an artificial economic coma
that the entire american economy had
been put into and all he had to do was
just step back and let the vaccines roll
out and that's it that's all he had to
do and he couldn't just do it instead he
had to toss money at things he had to
blow money into the economy creating
inflation he had to encourage the vax to
stay home and the unvexed to get fired
he had to tell everybody that they
somehow owed it to themselves not to go
back to work and we would take care of
you if you didn't go back to work and
we're going to restructure the economy
such that your decision-making process
would have no impact on whether you got
a payment from the federal government
and in the course of just nine months
joe biden has been able to take what was
the rosiest most optimistic vision of
what was going to happen to the united
states post his inauguration and
completely turn it on its head
right now the stats are devastating okay
and here's the inflation rates right now
the inflation rates are out of control
right now
according to the associated press today
inflation has now risen 5.4 from a year
ago it matches a 13-year high
that's the consumer price index rising
5.4 percent in september from a year ago
up slightly from august gain of 5.3
matching the increases in june and july
excluding the food and energy categories
and they do this in order to
artificially lower the inflation rate
but food and energy is where people
actually spend most of their money core
inflation rose 0.2 percent in september
and 4 compared with a year ago core
prices hit a three-decade high of 4.5 in
june the unexpected burst of inflation
this year reflects sharply higher prices
for food and energy but also new and
used cars hotel rooms airplane tickets
and furniture among other goods and
services
now they're going to try and blame
everybody else they're going to try and
blame the covid problem in asia and
factories and all of this but what we
really are seeing and this is the big
thing is a massive shortage of labor
according to cnbc and this is the stat
that matters right now there's over 10
million jobs in the united states that
are open
and that means that everybody is
clamoring for workers right now
and according to cnbc people are not
only not going back to work they are
dropping out of the workforce there's
only one way that you can make that
possible and that is by lying to the
american people that they can stay home
and we will pay for it it turns out that
to acclimate the american people to
basically
sitting home and waiting for the
government to take care of them takes
only about a year
uh i thought and i think a lot of people
thought that americans would not give up
their personal liberty and work
initiative quite that fast and most
americans still haven't but a
significant percentage of americans are
a huge percentage of americans were like
you know what i'm kind of comfortable
with this i'm kind of comfortable with
the idea that the government is just
going to pay me to stay at home
how else do you explain the fact that
4.3
million people left their jobs in august
that's unbelievable 4.3 million people
left their jobs in august
how right don't they have to put food on
the table the answer is they're waiting
for jobiden to pay them
the quits rate rose to 2.9 an increase
of 242 000 from the previous month which
saw a rate of 2.7 according to the
department's job openings and labor
turnover survey according to cnbc the
rate which is measured against total
employment is the highest in a data
series that goes back to december 2000.
going all the way back to december 2000
this is the highest quit rates we have
seen
right in in two decades quits have been
seen historically as a level of
confidence from workers who feel they
are secure in finding employment
elsewhere the labor dynamics have
changed during the covenanting crisis
workers have left their jobs because of
health concerns and child care issues
unique to the pandemic's circumstances
or alternatively workers have left their
jobs not because they are deeply worried
about child care they left their job
because joe biden is telling them that
if they stay home he is going to pay
them and democrats are saying the same
exact thing
and they are blaming the unvaxxed for
all of that
a total of 892 000 workers in the food
service and accommodation industries
left their jobs 721 000 retail workers
departed along with 534 000 in health
care and social assistance by the way i
would bet many of those people are the
unbaxed i bet a lot of those people are
unvaccinated people particularly in the
healthcare industry who said i would
rather not i'd rather lose my job
by not getting vast then take the
vaccine
so the mandate probably created some of
that unemployment as job openings and
hires fell in august the quits rate hit
a new series high surging along with the
rising covet cases and likely growing
concerns about working in the continuing
pandemic said lee schooled senior
economist at the econ at the economic
policy institute so they're going to
keep blaming the idea that people are
afraid to go to work because they're
afraid they're going to get covered at
work that is not true
it is not true people are not deeply
afraid they're going to get coveted at
work if they are and they are vast
particularly they are being stupid and
if they're unvacs they've had every
opportunity to get facts at this point
if you're afraid to go back to work that
is a you problem as i am fond of saying
because you have all of the solutions at
your fingertips
you can mask up if you'd like you have a
vaccine if you'd like we have
therapeutics now you should not be
afraid to go back to work at this point
in the pandemic and if you are it is
probably because you have been convinced
by the media and by joe biden that
number one you will get paid even if you
don't go back to work and number two you
have something gravely to fear while joe
biden restructures the entire economy
employment vacancies fell slightly to
10.4 million during the month
10.4 million
i mean that's that's that's an enormous
labor shortage you wonder why there are
bottlenecks right now that's why there
are bottlenecks
these stats are absolutely stunning
at least
the washington post is being a little
more honest about this eli rosenberg
says the number of people quitting their
jobs has surged to record highs pushed
by a combination of factors that include
americans sensing ample opportunity and
better pay elsewhere some 4.3 million
people quit jobs in august according to
the monthly survey about 2.9 percent of
the workforce according to new data
released tuesday from the department of
labor the phenomenon is being driven in
part by workers who are less willing to
endure inconvenient hours and poor
compensation quitting at this stage in
the pandemic to find better
opportunities elsewhere
okay except that the people who are
quitting many of them are not finding
better jobs elsewhere they're not taking
up those 10.4 million open jobs that's
why there's still 10 million open jobs
in the country
the reality is that many of them believe
that if they quit the government is
going to pick up after them
the high level of people quitting their
jobs is likely due in part to people
leaving jobs to take other positions but
the data does not specify why people are
quitting and where they are ending up
there's a lot of demand people are
seizing that opportunity and quitting
their jobs say some of the experts
but again
what we are seeing right now is that
workers are feeling confident that they
will be okay if they quit their jobs and
maybe that is because we sent them free
money for a year maybe that is because
the democrats would like to spend
another five trillion dollars sending
them free money
maybe it's because they see that the
build back better agenda is really about
the no work agenda for a lot of people
this is true in everything from the
earned income tax credit which really
has very little to do with earned income
to the restructuring of how welfare
programs work in this country which is
what happens under joe biden's plans
now the predictable results of this is
when there are not enough people working
you do get price inflation there's a
shortage of product the pipelines are
broken right people are not able to ship
the products where they need to go this
is why you are seeing rising prices so
the same people who are being celebrated
for quitting the workforce are also
having trouble actually paying for all
of this stuff
by the way many of them have savings
built up over the last year because the
government was sending them these
exorbitant checks every week
to shut everything down
according to yahoo news stakes could
soon become a champagne-like luxury
thanks to the failures of the supply
chains we shouldn't have supply chain
failures at this point we really should
not there's a lot of talk about this
during the pandemic supply chain
failures
now that we are pretty much past the
worst of this there really should not be
these concerns however says bloomberg
the boss of europe's top meat processor
said processor said beef will become a
luxury like champagne because of the
climate impact of producing it
beef is not going to be super climate
friendly said danish crown chief
executive officer jais valuers in an
interview with danish newspaper
berlinsky it will be a luxury product we
eat when we want to treat ourselves oh
good
also
the white house is warning of christmas
shortages
oh good okay so so it's amazing how fast
this administration went from santa
claus to the grinch
right they went real fast from guys we
are just going to hand you free money
and everything is going to be great
we're going to build back better
they went real fast from that too also
you're not going to be able to get toys
for kids on christmas because let's face
it we have jack this economy is so bad
it is beyond recognition
according to reuters white house
officials scrambling to relieve global
supply bottlenecks choking us ports
highways and railways warn that
americans may face higher prices and
some empty shelves this christmas season
the supply crisis driven in part by the
global 19 pandemic not only threatens to
dampen u.s spending at a critical time
it also poses a political risk for
president joe biden
the white house has been trying to
tackle inflation-inducing supply
bottlenecks of everything from meat to
semiconductors and formed a task force
in june that meets weekly and named a
bottleneck czar to push private sector
companies to ease snarls wow well if as
long as your point is our man we know
that the history of czars in american
federal government wildly successful you
remember that barack obama had a czar
for pretty much everything and none of
those stars were much more successful
than the tsar who was executed by the
russian revolution all of those stars
were basically failures
biden himself plans to meet with top
executives from walmart and home depot
and with unions and other stakeholders
on wednesday to discuss efforts to
relieve transportation bottlenecks
before delivering a speech on this well
if he if he talks we know that when joe
biden talks number one words barely make
it out of his face but number two the
world changes in magnificent ways when
joe biden talks probably the entire
labor shortage that we're experiencing
in the country
if he just jabbers at walmart and home
depot probably they'll be relieved
i know that if there's if there's one
group of people who are not worried at
all about the supply chain bottlenecks
it's probably home depot and walmart
they're probably doing nothing but then
joe biden that man that great glorious
man he will jump on them and he will
spur them to new heights
he will he will force them to really get
enthusiastic about getting products to
their customers because if there's one
thing joe biden knows it's how things
ought to run making sure that things get
there on time if there's one thing joe
biden knows it's how to make the trains
run on time
yeah and if you believe that then i
don't know what to tell you you uh
you're the sucker you're the sucker okay
in just a second we'll get to more of
this because joe biden's plans are going
to exacerbate all of this
things are going to get worse before
they get better because joe biden has
absolutely screwed the pooch i mean from
every perceivable angle we'll get more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about your sleep quality so i am on
the road and i'm staying at a very nice
hotel i'll be honest with you it's a
great hotel but there's one thing that i
miss more than anything else except for
my family and that of course is my helix
sleep mattress helix has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes directly to
your doorstrip for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
they've got a 10-year warranty you have
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you absolutely will
helix has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night sleep is
never far away just head on over to
helixsleep.com
take their two minutes leave quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that gives you the best sleep
of your life helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep dot com slash men go check them
out right now alrighty so
the consequences of joe biden's crappy
policy are being seen pretty much
everywhere shoppers are upset with the
fact that the dollar tree has been
raising its prices and you know people
in the media they laugh at this because
only rubes shop at the dollar tree of
course only these middle class and lower
class people shop i mean the people who
write your news they go to whole foods
excuse me they drive their teslas to
whole foods like aoc but if you are a if
you're like a regular person who goes to
dollar tree and you're worried about the
fact that now stuff costs more than a
buck that's just because you don't
understand we're building back better
guys
one of the last true dollar stores
dollar tree is about to give in to
inflation and rising shipping costs and
many long time shoppers are not happy
about it
willa davenport has been shopping dollar
tree for years we found her picking up
some paper towels and some birthday
cards at a time when drugstore greeting
cards can cost six bucks here there's
still a dollar as are wrapping paper and
gift bags food home decor even halloween
and christmas items i don't think it's
right for them to raise surprises you go
in there to get for a dollar and then
they tell you it's a dollar fifty they
gonna change all their signs maybe this
lady ought to start chanting let's go
brandon because it's very clear who is
responsible for all of this and it ain't
dollar tree i think dollar tree is
desperate to raise its prices on its
customers
so that they have to put the lie in the
front of their store that it's the
dollar tree
and meanwhile over in minneapolis
they're reporting that choppers are
going to see empty shelves on black
friday so you're going to go out for the
sale there ain't going to be nothing
there
holiday shoppers are already being
warned to hit the stores early marissa
silva a toy expert says the industry is
being hit hard by the shipping crisis
silva says there's a delay of about six
to eight weeks for a lot of toys he also
warns by black friday there may not be
much on the store shelves ongoing supply
chain disruptions and that microchip
shortage will both cut down on inventory
and drive up the costs of toys that are
available
okay so all of this you can lay at the
feet of the current president of the
united states the imf for its part is
warning of inflation and a slower
slowing recovery as it lowers its
forecast
according to the imf the economic growth
forecast for the united states was
paired back to six percent from the
seven percent growth projected in july
because of softening consumption and a
large decline in inventory caused by
supply chain bottlenecks
the imf lowered its entire 2021 global
growth forecast to 5.9 percent down from
the six percent projected in july
remember there are people who are
projecting that the gdp in the united
states was going to grow by double
digits this year and now we're down to
six percent which is
strong but doesn't really make up for
the fact that we completely destroyed
our entire economy last year
meanwhile the head of the federal
reserve bank of atlanta raphael bostock
he said on tuesday that um things are
going to get worse he says it's becoming
increasingly clear that the features of
this episode that is animated price
pressures
mainly the intense and widespread supply
chain disruptions will not be brief
he said data from multiple sources point
to these lasting longer than most
initially thought by this definition the
forces are not transitory not transitory
and well maybe you know it says maybe
i'm getting this wrong
maybe this isn't a mistake by joe biden
maybe this is part of the plan maybe
this is the feature not the bug because
if you look at the way that the media
are reporting for example so many people
dropping out of the labor force instead
of saying well this is driving up prices
and it's creating supply chain model
nuts and it means that we are borrowing
money from the future to pay people to
stay out of work right now instead of
doing all of that
so many people in the media are cheering
because what this is really showing is
just showing that our workers have
leverage they have leverage over their
companies
this goes all the way back to last year
when the irrepressible
highly intelligent let me tell you she
is so smart alexander ocasio-cortez so
fresh so unbelievably face
from new york
she said this is last year april of last
year there's a lot of talk about people
getting back to work
is when trump was president and she said
she doesn't think people should go back
to work they shouldn't go back to work
they should use the opportunity of the
government paying them to stay home to
demand quote unquote more of their
employers there's only one problem of
course which is that it takes two to
tango and if the employers go under
because there is a stagnation that is
driven
by inflation
then those jobs are going to disappear
right now there's 10 million open jobs
but if the workers stay out of work then
eventually the prices get too high and
then people stop buying things and then
you have full-scale economic stagnation
and when you pay people to stay home
then maybe it's not about leveraging
their employers maybe it's about them
having an unrealistic expectation of how
the world is supposed to work
but this is the deal for democrats a lot
of democrats truly believe that the way
you restructure work is you pay people
to stay home
only in america
does the president when the president
tweets about liberation does he mean go
back to work when we
you know have this discussion about
going going back or reopening
i think a lot of people should just say
no we're not going back to that
we're not going back to working
70 hour weeks just so that we could put
food on the table and not even
feel any sort of semblance of security
in our lives okay so question who pays
for all this
really who pays for all this
well the answer for the democrats is
nobody
the answer for the democrats is that we
just keep spending and it doesn't matter
if we have no
actual ability to spend more or this is
going to do long-term damage to future
economic prospects the idea is that in
order to rethink reimagine work
reimagine reality all we have to do is
just wishcast it
we can we can stay home from work pretty
much forever and we can leverage our
employers into paying us all a hundred
thousand dollars a year for a job that
really on the market is probably worth
forty thousand dollars a year we can do
that so long as the government just pays
us to stay home and then we have
leverage so if the government
artificially creates leverage and
leverages private industry in order to
do all this stuff and then taxes private
industry to pay for all of that then
magically this aerobros of economic
idiocy will somehow generate prosperity
that is that is the basic idea here
and democrats are pushing this very hard
like i don't think that at this point
they like i don't think that joe biden
sees this as a crisis i think that again
gensake and joe biden might see this as
kind of an opera it's a political crisis
but it is also an opportunity for them
to reimagine rem like just reimagining
policing meant get rid of the cops and
then let people die in the big cities
reimagining economics means tell people
not to go back to work and they
shouldn't go back to work they should
never go back to their terrible
employers until those employers are
paying them outsized wages driving up
the prices of goods and services forcing
people to pay more forcing people to go
without and that will somehow cure
things we'll get some more on this in
just one second first let's talk about
the simple fact that if you have a
medical problem you really ought to get
it solved that's particularly true for a
nagging medical problem like erectile
dysfunction when something is off in the
bedroom a lot of people try not to think
about it well what are you waiting for
just go get it taken care of you can do
it quickly and easily at getroman.com
ben right now with roman you get a free
online evaluation and ongoing care for
ed all the way from the comfort and
privacy of your home a us licensed
healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships you
free with two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com ben complete an online
visit take care of your ed without
leaving your home complete an online
visit today to connect with a healthcare
professional and get it taken care of go
to getroman.com right now you'll get 15
bucks off your very first month it is
really time to get your ed taken care of
remember get started today you'll save
15 bucks on your first order of ed
treatment again that's getroman.com
right now you get 15 bucks off your
first month of ed treatment at
getroman.com don't let a nagging medical
problem worry you to death instead head
on over to getroman.com ben and get it
taken care of right now so again the
idea from the democratic left seems to
be
that it is good that people aren't going
back to work because finally workers
have leverage okay so here is the
problem the prices continue to rise
because when you have shortages too many
dollars chasing too few goods you get
inflation
right now rises in wages that are being
celebrated by the media as well workers
have leverage
those rises in wages are being outpaced
by inflation so real wages are actually
down at this point because those wildly
increased wages are being outpaced by
the price of goods and services so who's
going to make up that gap presumably the
government is going to make up that gap
now where's the government going to get
all that money according to the
democrats they're going to get it from
exactly the private industries they're
seeking to extract money from right now
for the employees
so basically the people who are
producing in the society are not only
going to be paying the people who are
not producing to stay home they are also
going to be paying additional
artificially high wages to people
because the government is paying people
to stay home and they're going to be
paying high additional taxes as well no
way that this is going to go wrong in
any particular way
now this it's all going to go right
now you might think at this point that
if joe biden had
any semblance of political acumen he
might rethink what he is doing here he
might use what joe manchin and kirsten
cinema are doing here as an opportunity
to pair back his expectations as an
opportunity not to go for broke like an
idiot but instead to say okay what if we
did a little spending here and a little
spending there walk back that 3.5
trillion i get to let joe manchin and
kristen cinema be the bad guys to the
progressive bass but i get to be a hero
to the progressives for fighting mansion
in cinema and then i get what i really
want which is some spending but not like
an unbelievable amount of spending and
maybe the economy goes back to normal
that is not what this administration is
doing they are so committed to their
ideological vision of how the world
should work that they are neglecting how
the world actually does work
and so you got nancy pelosi continuing
to push forward the notion that we
should have trillions and trillions in
spending and they're just going to lie
to you about it
democrats are struggling to come
together on this build back better
agenda and they're trying to figure out
exactly how they pair things back to
meet the requirements of joe manchin and
kirsten cinema
and one of the things that nancy pelosi
is pushing forward
is the question of whether they need to
cut full programs which is what manchin
and cinema want or whether pelosi is
mostly interested in shrinking the term
of the deal
right she said
that she's not going to say what
proposals will be dropped from this
giant boondoggle of a package but
her most her biggest interest is in
shortening the length of time the
proposals will be in effect okay so what
that means is that instead of budgeting
out 3.5 trillion dollars over 10 years
we'll budget a trillion and a half bucks
over three years and we'll put all those
programs in place and then we'll dare
the republicans to let those programs
die right which is usually the
democratic game right because once you
get people on the heroine of government
money it is very hard to get people off
the heroin of government money people
like to vote themselves money it's just
a simple fact of reality which is why
the government continues to grow so
nancy pelosi's plan is just to lie to
you
right they're not actually going to make
the package smaller they're just going
to lie to you by making the term shorter
democrats by the way i mean really does
show that democrats want to make
everybody dependent because it should
not even be a battle
as to whether these programs should be
means tested for example right so
democrats entire stick is we got to help
the poor right this is this is their
public stick we got to help the poor
it's the poor who are really suffering
we need redistributionist policies
because the people at the bottom rungs
of economic society are the ones who
suffer the most now the reality is in
the united states we spend an awful lot
of money on the people in the bottom
quintile
we do our social services are extremely
expensive tens of thousands of dollars
per family are spent every year by the
federal and state government on people
who are at the bottom level of the
economic
of the economic ladder
that is just
forget all of the propaganda about how
we leave the poor to die in the united
states we absolutely do not we have a
very solid social safety net system it
is very large we spend an awful lot of
money it is in fact comparable to many
western european countries in terms of
how much we spend we are not a
full-scale gung-ho capitalist don't take
care of the poor country
we are a capitalist country with a very
strong social safety net which has been
built up over many years
has not done nearly what it was promised
to do but that is the ins so but here's
the thing democrats aren't even telling
the truth okay because when they say
they want to help the poor what they
really mean is they want to make more
people up to and including middle class
and upper middle class people more
dependent on government programs it is
an ideological goal to have the
government take the place of private
initiative in american life which is why
there's a debate right now among
democrats over means testing
many programs now means testing just
means that if you are richer and you can
afford something the government won't
pay for it and if you are poorer and and
you can't afford something the
government will help you pay for it now
you would think okay that's at least
according to democratic lights logical
right i mean i thought that was the
whole shtick is that we're trying to
help people who are poor but democrats
are debating this because again the real
goal is not to help the poor the real
goal is how many people can we get
hooked on our government programs so
then they vote for us in the future
according to the wall street journal
choosing which americans should be
eligible for benefits in a proposed
expansion of the social safety net is
one of the main challenges vexing
democrats who are attempting to slim
down their healthcare education child
care and climate bill in the coming
weeks
on one side of the debate over means
testing are democrats like senator joe
manchin who wants to target the
government aid to low-income americans
arguing that narrowing eligibility for
the programs to those most in need will
be a cheaper and more efficient use of
taxpayer funds on the other side are
both progressive and centrist democrats
who want to make programs like
subsidized child care free preschool and
two years of free community college
available to americans up and down the
income ladder invoking the legacies of
social security and medicare each
decades old and broadly available to
americans these democrats view universal
programs as both more effective at
helping americans in need and better at
winning enduring political support and
that last part of the sentence is the
part that matters because here's the
thing if you make these programs
available to the poor then the rest of
the population might have an interest
every so often in looking in and seeing
on what the programs work and maybe we
should shift them but if you just
helicopter cash to everybody then
everybody goes oh i'm going to vote for
the helicopter cash too one thing this
article does not note is that medicare
and social security have essentially
been bankrupt for years and will
continue to be bankrupt as the count as
the country gets older
because they are giant ponzi schemes
essentially
pelosi has not indicated where she
stands on income eligibility she said
this week democrats could pair back the
number of programs while also looking at
reducing the number of years funded to
bring down the price of the bill
she said mostly would be cutting back on
years and something like that again it's
all games but this is all about
electoral they want the massive shift in
how americans think of the government if
you think democrats hated the last year
democrats have loved the last year is
their favorite thing that has ever
happened in the history of mankind it is
great the government came in and they
paid they shut down every private
business in the country essentially and
everybody who's a keyboard warrior got
to stay home and work
in the safety of their own homes
everybody else became ward of the
government
democrats are like how do we prolong
this how do we make this happen
and for everybody else who has not
bought into the newfangled democratic
line that work is bad and that everybody
must be freed of the burdens of work in
order so we can all become pottery
artists and painters and poets
people who don't buy into that are like
why don't you just let things go back to
the way that they were and democracy
nope gotta build back better
so this has led to the bizarre spectacle
of nancy pelosi claiming that this bill
which is not like americans are not up
for this they are not if you ask
americans would you like free money in
polls they will say yes if you ask
americans whether they are ready to take
on trillions of dollars more more in
cost and incentivize people not to work
in the middle of an inflationary spiral
and a stagnating economy most americans
are not up for it
nancy pelosi
she gives away the game here uh so she
says a couple of things that are really
incredible she did a press conference
yesterday first she says americans
support the bill even if they say they
don't which is a hell of a take on
public opinion here's nancy pelosi
one of the things in the bill is the
continuation of the buying tax credit
that is child tax credit that is in the
um
within the rescue package
that has
great appeal do people know where it
springs from though but it is a vast
bill it has a lot in it and we'll have
to continue to make sure the public does
but whether they know it or not they
overwhelmingly support it whether they
whether they know what's in the belt or
not
then they support which which goes
really well with her old-fashioned
statement about obamacare that we'll
have to pass it to know what's in it
and then
i'm sensing a pattern here which is that
so long as she can be completely opaque
about what exactly she's about to do to
the american people she can do whatever
she wants and then declare that the
general the russoian general will has
somehow empowered her to do these things
by the way she is gonna get a it's gonna
be hard for her next year when she's in
the minority in the house again because
of all of this sort of stuff okay then
she's very angry because she says yeah
well members of the press are like well
it's not that popular a lot of americans
are having doubts about this like
like you're really
not making a strong case for this bill
and nancy pelosi is like why don't you
make a case for the bill
now this really gives away the game
because the way democrats view the press
is as they're lacking the press are just
the democratic pr operatives and nancy
pelosi basically just says that she's
like go do your job
here she goes dentures are clacking
only about 10 of americans describe
themselves as knowing a lot of specific
things that are in the reconciliation
package and that the majority don't know
anything at all so do you think you need
to do a better job at messaging and
going forward how do you sell this if
ultimately well i think you all could do
a better job of selling it to be very
frank with you because every time i come
here i go through the list
family medical leave climate
the issues that are in there
um you could do a better job of selling
it maybe the american people aren't
deeply worried right now about climate
change which might affect the the
gdp of the globe by a slight percentage
over the course of a century maybe
they're more worried about the fact that
they're having trouble buying a house
that they're having trouble paying rent
and they're having trouble putting food
on the table or paying their gas bill
maybe that's what americans are most
concerned about right now and it's your
job to sell it and you suck at your job
and so you're blaming your pr machine
i do love the democrats just assume that
it's the press's job to sell their
garbage
meanwhile nancy pelosi is pushing
forward the idea that there should be no
debt limit the house is trying to raise
the debt limit again
because of course that doesn't matter
because money's imaginary to these
people anyway
and seriously how many of these
democratic leaders have ever run a
business like actually run a business
i know that that's become a pass a
question since the mitt romney days but
it turns out that running a business is
kind of hard and then you actually have
to have some know-how to do it and yet
democrats think that not only should
they be running a business they should
be running your business
here's nancy pelosi saying that you know
the debt limit getting let's just get
rid of it because we don't need
responsibility
there are all kinds of um
suggestions that members have one that
really was
endorsed a while back by mitch mcconnell
but who knows that you know who knows
but it was to to um
the
manifestation of it now mr yarmouth and
mr
um
boyle put forth
puts the responsibility on the secretary
of the treasury
to make the determination to lift the
debt ceiling
that decision could be overruled by the
congress are you in favor of that idea i
think it has merit yes i do think it has
merit of course she thinks it has merit
because anything that relieves congress
of the responsibility of coming in and
spending has merit according to nancy
pelosi and if you think this isn't going
to be intrusive for you it is going to
be intrusive all of this is going to be
intrusive it is all about controlling
your life it's all about control but
don't worry if you give them ultimate
it's just like covet if you give them
ultimate power they'll fix all your
problems they'll hit that magic
government button and then all of your
problems will be solved you can stay
home you'll never have to go to work all
you have to do is just sit at home and
wait for the government checks to arrive
and the government will take care of all
your needs now all they're going to need
in return is for you to just give them
pretty much everything access to all
your records you're going to need to
give them access to pretty much all of
your life decisions they're going to
have to control how you educate your
kids they're gonna have to control how
you take money out of the bank one of
the provisions of this bill
is that the irs is going to be able to
essentially audit any transaction from a
bank over 600
if you take 600 bucks out of the bank
the irs is going to be staffed up so
that they can check into every
transaction you do over 600 in the
united states which is unbelievable here
is nancy pelosi being very enthusiastic
about it she says absolutely we need to
keep it it's crucial we keep that
um so americans are starting to be
worried about this do you think that
this paid for of of giving the irs more
money to crack down on
taxes
is going to stay in the reconciliation
yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes okay so why
why well the answer is control now the
excuse they're making for why they need
to audit your 600 withdrawals from the
bank is because they're going after
billionaires which is just ridiculous on
its face so janet yellen the treasury
secretary she literally said this here
she was explaining that the reason they
need to audit 600 transactions from
banks is to stop the billionaires from
being tax frauds
you want banks to report transactions of
six hundred dollars or more that's what
the irs wants
does this mean that the government is
trying to peek into our pocketbooks if
you want to look at 600 transactions
absolutely not i think this proposal has
been seriously mischaracterized
if somebody reports an income of ten
thousand dollars and they had three
million dollars
go out of their checking account that
tells the irs that's a that's an
individual you might audit okay i just
have a question if you really think this
is about billionaires you're out of your
damned mind this is crazy talk okay
janet yellen says there there's a lot of
tax fraud and cheating that is going on
and the tax fraud cheating is happening
at the 600 level and that we have to
hold billionaires accountable
let me just say this if you somehow
become a billionaire by withdrawing
money from the bank 600 at a time
you know amazing job because that would
only take 1 million 666 666 transactions
to make it a billionaire
literally about
190 transactions an hour
something on that order for a year then
you'd be a billionaire so probably the
yeah she's cracking down on billionaires
there's nothing with monitoring your
individual spent no no no they would
never do that they would never do that
they're not trying to control your life
at all meanwhile speaking of trying to
control your life we'll get to joe biden
and the big coveted battle that is
breaking out right now first i am
thrilled to announce an incredible app
that everyone who buys gas needs to know
about and this makes a lot of sense for
you right now considering the spiking
gas prices the service is called get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up you just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
shapiro and you get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that is up
to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside so you download the app
for free use promo code shapiro you get
up to 50 cents a gallon cash back on
your first tank of gas a lot of money
considering how expensive gas is right
now some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to three hundred
bucks a month in cash back there's no
catch the cash back gets added directly
to your account you can cash out any
time to your bank account paypal or an
egift card for amazon and other brands
just download the free get upside app
use promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank of gas that is code shapiro
there's never been a better time to save
on cast than right now go check them out
right now get that get upside app and
use promo code shapiro to get 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your very first tank
of gas alrighty if you didn't catch
backstage last night you missed
the melodic smokey mic and the god king
and um so congratulations to you but
actually the show was really good and
and more than that you didn't hear all
of our exciting news as i mentioned
before we have many new projects in the
pipeline that are going to change the
way you stream here at the daily wire we
recognize the important role that
entertainment plays in our world we have
been working overtime to make sure that
we are bringing you the non-woke
contents you can't find literally
anywhere else so we've got a brand new
comedy series we are bringing you
featuring none other than adam carolla
and we've got our brand new film
starring the fearless gina carano it's
titled terror on the prairie it's
currently in production in montana and
last but definitely not least we're
dropping the teaser trailer for shut in
our first original production
it's a great movie the script is
fantastic it's a 60-second look into a
thriller you're not going to want to
miss we seriously cannot wait to share
the final products with you so keep your
eyes and ears peeled for updates on
their release dates you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
one of the ways that joe biden is
crimping at the economy obviously is
keeping the cove pandemic alive now i
can't say this enough i really cannot
say this enough on an individual level
you now have the ability to prevent
yourself from dying from covet you get a
vaccine the vaccines are very effective
forget all the propaganda that you're
hearing from many people on the right
and many people on the left the reality
is the vaccines do prevent people from
getting hospitalized and dying and when
we talk about antibodies waning i got a
question about this this morning from a
staffer actually when we talk about
antibodies waning from for example the
phasor vaccine that does not mean that
you are now in exactly the same risk
situation you were before you took the
pfizer vaccine it just means you might
get a breakthrough infection because the
way antibodies work is your body
generates them when there is live a
virus in your body when the virus goes
away the antibodies go away but you
still have t-cell and b-cell memory
which means your body remembers how to
fight the virus if you get a
breakthrough infection which is why if
you get a fish or a vaccine and then you
get a breakthrough infection the
infection is really mild as opposed to
what it might have been had you not had
the pfizer vaccine okay that said if you
get faxed you're good to go if you're
not vacs you've chosen not to be facts
if you choose not to be vaxxed and you
want to wear a kn95 you can get those
pretty much everywhere at this point so
for all intents and purposes we are done
now but joe biden cannot let go of this
the reason he cannot let go of this is
because he set a standard the democrats
set a standard okay this is tied into
their entire economic program as well
the standard is they were not only going
to build back better their building back
better blella
was going to be about the match button
it's all that magic government button if
you hit it
everything is solved joe biden promised
he was going to solve covet and yet
there are still people who have covet it
turns out the government cannot
eviscerate disease disease will always
be with us government cannot evacuate
poverty poverty will always be with us
doesn't mean there aren't things you can
do to mitigate but in the end government
cannot solve overwhelming problems that
just exist in humanity government can't
solve death government can solve many of
the things that make life risky
government cannot do all those things
but joe biden came into office promising
he would do all of those things and now
when it turns out that what he really
needs to do is say the same thing that
trump said last year which is we need to
learn to live with the virus we need to
go back to our regular lives and just
deal with it instead of joe biden saying
that and he can't do it he literally
can't do it because he ran against trump
saying it last year
now joe biden is stuck in the situation
of having to say well if if i were if
only if only the unvaxxed would do what
i say it's not me it's not my fault it's
not my fault for making a stupid promise
that i never could have kept it's not my
fault it's everybody else's fault it's
everyone else's fault and so what i'm
going to use i'm going to use the mass
power of the federal government to cram
down my vision of what should happen
with vaccines now he knows that that is
not going to solve the problem he knows
that
for all the people who are like no he
thinks that the vaccine mandates he
knows the vaccine mandates aren't going
to solve a damn thing he knows that
because people are quitting he knows
that because large swaths of the country
are not going to comply he knows that
because when he does this he actually
makes people less likely to comply
right the people who are the hardest
core of the vaccine
and the anti-vax folks
those folks are not going to be
convinced by a doddering senile old man
yelling at them that they might lose
their jobs instead they're just going to
turn it into a liberty issue
right they because at that point it does
become a liberty issue
and the vaccines didn't have to be a
liberty issue they could have just been
a science issue
and then you choose to take them or you
choose not to take them but your liberty
has not been infringed but once joe
biden starts mandating at every level he
can that you must take the vaccine this
doesn't become a science issue anymore
it now becomes a liberty issue and once
you make it a liberty issue people see
virtue in not being vast so more people
are going to not vacs at this point
and the predictable result of this of
course is that you will get more
infections you'll get some more death
now i will note it is incredible to see
michigan which has a lower vaccination
rate than florida is currently having
ten thousand cases of cove a day and
they're in the middle of a bit of a
coveted spike it's going to get worse as
the winter goes on because people go
indoors when people go indoors they
breathe on each other and then covert
gets spread watch for it in the
northeast this winter right now it is
still nice and warm in most parts of the
northeast the weather in new york right
now
is in the 60s and 70s this week all the
way up to the near 80s
you have to wait for the weather in new
york to drop to the 30s and the 40s and
then people start going indoors and then
you're going to see a bit of a covered
spike because that's just how this works
okay but put aside the fact that the
media are utterly unconcerned by blue
states that have coveted spikes that
doesn't matter to them that's why we got
a lot of coverage of florida but not
louisiana even though louisiana was
suffering a per capita problem that was
worse than florida's
okay the the real problem here for joe
biden is that the american people don't
trust him on this issue anymore
according to axios ipso's poll released
on tuesday only 42 of americans trust
the president a great deal or a fair
amount on providing accurate information
on the virus
that is a 16 point decline from the
inauguration
according to cliff young president of
ipsos u.s public affairs he's basically
he's basically losing the expectations
game once the delta variant raised its
ugly head it affected people's lives now
they're adjusting their expectations
which is not good for him now the
reality is that
the
expectations that he set were never
accurate but he has to blame somebody he
must and this is why joe biden and the
white house are cramming down these
vaccine mandates and that is having
downstream economic effects because
again the only reason to issue vaccine
mandates is because you're implying that
the vaccines are not in fact protective
so you need to mandate the unbacks get
it to protect the vax so you're telling
the facts that they're unsafe you're
telling the unvacs you're going to come
to their house and inject them in the
arm basically
and people are going to resist that
and then people don't go back to work so
the problem becomes worse but joe biden
gets to pretend that it's everybody
else's fault
and this is what is happening right now
is this name and shame and go after
everybody else to avoid the simple fact
that joe biden is an incompetent rube
who sucks at his job and is barely some
ambulance the man can barely sleepwalk
that's that's where we are okay so
speaking of the vaccine mandates here is
the current status so the osha rule
has now apparently been submitted to the
office of management and budget this is
the famous osha rule that is going to
mandate that all companies with over 100
employees have to either vax the people
who work for them or test them weekly
that has now been submitted to the omb
the omb has not made that rule public at
this point we don't know where the holes
in it are we can't have our lawyers who
are waiting on standby ready to go to
appeal this to a court like as fast as
humanly possible they can't do anything
yet because the rule has neither been
released nor finalized at this point
but the democrats have a problem when it
comes to this rule the biggest problem
is how the hell are you going to enforce
it you have hundreds of thousands of
businesses in the united states
tens of thousands of businesses with
over 100 employees how do you even
enforce something like this
according to nbc news businesses not in
compliance with the mandate could face
fines from the government but osha which
doesn't have the staff for this will
likely rely on voluntary compliance
focusing its resources on repeat
offenders now we know that they're
probably going to come out at us
obviously because we've been very public
about the fact that we have no intent of
complying with this unconstitutional
mandate this violation of liberty
but for a lot of other businesses
that ain't going to happen so the real
point here is to make the rule the real
point is this is joe biden just
signaling to his base who are
disproportionately vast that he is a
good man who is trying to do what they
want him to do now here's the thing
people who are vast
if you are worried about whether your
neighbor is back you're doing it wrong
you're not protected
end of story there's still not a good
excuse for why you are super upset with
your neighbor for being unvaxxed and
being in the same room as you
that's just the reality but it's not
about solving the problem it's never
about solving the problem it's always
about the future agenda it's all it's
always about the thing that's behind
what they are saying it's about
okay for the biden administration it's
not about making the economy stronger
it's about completely reshifting the way
that we do economics in this country to
make people dependent on government when
it comes to covid it is not about
solving the problem by more people being
vaxxed which would require you to
actually have conversations with the
unbaxed maybe take into account natural
immunity which this administration
steadfastly refuses to do
it's not about any of that it's about
signaling to his base that he's doing
his best and it's just those other guys
who are the bad guys
i mean how stupid are some of these
these mandates from the biden
administration
so biden does have the osha rule which
is private companies but then he also
has one rule that's in effect right now
which applies to federal contractors so
any company that is a federal contractor
already has a vax mandate
here is how stupid this rule is
according to the safer
federalworkforce.gov
plan
biden's federal contract or vax order
applies to people who work 100 from home
i'm not kidding you you work in your own
house
and your company if it contracts with
the federal government must vax you or
test you
quote an individual working on a covered
contract from their residence is a
covered contractor employee and must
comply with the vaccination requirement
for covered contractor employees even if
the employee never works at either a
covered contract or workplace or a
federal workplace during the performance
of the contract a covered contractor
employee's residence is not a covered
contractor workplace so while in the
residence the individual need not comply
with requirements for covered contractor
workplaces including relating to masking
and physical distancing even while
working on a covered contract so in
other words if you're in your own house
the federal government will be kind
enough to let you not mask in your own
home but you still have to be either
vast or tested every week to comply with
the mandate and for a company to comply
with the mandate
meanwhile the southwest ceo right
southwest has been plagued by massive
flight cancellations they keep saying
it's the weather or alternative issues
we all know what this is okay we're all
talking to people who work for southwest
people are sticking out they're saying
they're not going to comply with the vax
mandate
right now southwest is because they do
some work with the federal government
they're a federal contractor which means
that the deadline for them to comply
with the vax mandate is early november
early december
and they are suffering some pretty
significant blowback from both the the
union of southwest employees and also
from just employees generally
the southwest ceo admitted yesterday
yeah it really is joe biden we didn't
want to do this airline mandate because
we don't think it's necessary but joe
biden is pushing us so we have to
as i think you probably know i've never
been
in favor of corporations imposing that
kind of a mandate i'm not in favor of
that never have been
but the
executive order from president biden
mandates that all federal employees and
then all federal contractors which
covers uh all the major airlines
uh have to have a mandate and a vaccine
in place by december the 8th so we're
working through that
okay so you know it's funny how the
current southwest cancellations have
nothing to do with the biden mandate but
pretty much that's all everybody is
talking about is the biden mandate okay
so this has come to a head in the states
of texas and florida so florida and and
so texas has now basically issued a law
saying that private businesses are not
going to be able to mandate
that their employees get vast or tested
now
here's my view of this private business
can do what they want because this is
still a free country if you are dumb
enough to mandate that your employees
get vaxxed
your problem and those employees are
perfectly welcome to walk across the
street and find someplace else to work
the state should not be telling private
employers what to do on a general level
i don't believe that private employers
have to bake the cake i don't believe
the private employers have to comply
with vax mandates and i don't believe
the private employers should be forced
not to vax mandate okay right private
employers are private employers
with that said i don't think that the
federal government should be doing this
either
so now you have
these companies who are sort of trapped
in between because the federal
government was stupid enough to try and
push these vast mandates and now texas
is saying we'll find you if you do do
the max mandates so what do you do right
if you are an employer in the city in
the state of texas do you comply with
the feds or do you comply with the state
which one do you do
this is the current dilemma
according to the ap
the dust up will almost certainly end up
in court since gop attorneys general in
nearly half of states have vowed to sue
once the osha rule is enforced
the details are still unannounced more
conservative justices are on the bench
of course the outcome isn't entirely i
love that the media keep trying to claim
that the courts have long upheld vaccine
mandates yes from states not from the
federal government and not via osha
emergency rules
okay but again this is not about making
things better for this administration
this is not what it's about posing
here's jen saki from the white house
explaining that they are going to
implement these mandates across the
country
when the president announced
his vaccine
mandates for businesses that of course
we're waiting on osha regulations for as
a next step um that was pursuant to
federal law and the implementation of
federal law because it's an executive
order so our intention is to implement
and continue to work to implement these
requirements across the country
including in the states where there are
attempts to oppose them
okay meanwhile she of course is
attacking texas in florida and
suggesting they're putting politics
ahead of public health which is an
incredible statement
from an administration that has shifted
its opinion on every major area of this
pandemic and openly admits it's using
the pandemic in order to push forward
political policies on climate change and
health care here's jenn saki going after
texas again this administration is far
more angry at texas and florida and
people who defy their unconstitutional
mandates than they are at for example
the chinese government that unleashed
this virus
or than they are at people who continue
to violate the liberties of individual
american citizens it's pretty incredible
here's jensaki
governor abbott's executive order
banning mandates and i would also note
announcement by governor desantis this
morning essentially banning the
implementation of mandates
fit a familiar pattern that we've seen
of putting politics ahead of public
health
over 700 000 american lives have been
lost due to covet 19 including more than
56 000 in florida and over 68 000
in texas and every leader should be
focused on supporting efforts to save
lives and end the pandemic i noticed
that when she did her little litany of
how many people have died from
coronavirus in particular states she
didn't do the age-adjusted stat
on per capita deaths per state i noticed
she didn't do that
it turns out that a lot of people who
live in texas it turns out that there
are just a ton of people who live in
florida these are very very populous
states but i did notice that she uh she
was not citing the actual number of
total deaths by state because if she did
she might have to mention that number
one is california which has 70 000
deaths or that number four is new york
which has 56 000 deaths
or that the following states are
pennsylvania illinois and new jersey
which have thirty thousand twenty eight
thousand twenty seven thousand deaths
and she's only gonna cite the the evil
evil terrible no good very bad states of
texas and florida which defy the federal
government
what is this going to turn into it's
going to turn into
spy on your neighbor that is the next
move according to nbc news
president joe biden says his sweeping
covenant 19 vaccination and testing
mandate will boost the economy and save
lives but as businesses prepare for the
new requirement they're wondering not
only what will be in the regulation but
how it will be enforced the mandate
which will apply to organizations with
at least 100 employees and cover an
estimated 80 million workers has already
drawn threats of lawsuits from two dozen
republican attorneys general and
prompted some people to vow to quit
their jobs
the osha
was already expected was already
handling a broad mission prior to the
new rule to stretch its resources the
agency typically prioritizes high-risk
industries and targets repeat offenders
but osha only has 862 inspectors in
early 2020. so you're talking about 80
million employees that have to be
audited by 862 inspectors
experts say the agency's small size
relative to its responsibilities means
it cannot enforce the rule by deploying
a large number of inspectors
while osha is now hiring training takes
time david michaels who ran osha for
seven years says he doesn't think these
new inspectors will be out in the field
anytime soon
according to former osha senior policy
adviser debbie berkowitz quote it would
take 160 years for osha to get into
every workplace just once it's an
understaffed under-resourced agency to
begin with
so according to
one of these experts
osha is going to tell employers they
have to make sure potentially infectious
workers don't enter the workplace and
they can do that in a number of
different ways that includes regular
testing and close tracking of worker
compliance by businesses or even work
from home requirements
if businesses don't abide by the
regulation osha will have some levers
they can impose heavy fines publicize to
workers that they can complain if their
employer is not complying and they can
do spot inspections
but a key aspect of enforcing this
requirement differentiating it from some
other osha regulations will be the
reaction of employees at risk of
catching covet in the workplace who will
serve as a force multiplier experts say
lawrence gaston professor of public
health at johns hopkins says quote the
vast majority of employees want everyone
to be vaccinated it's only a small but
vocal minority who don't what you have
to do is capture the attention of the
silent majority and have them blow the
whistle on any employer
encouraging whistleblowing is an
extraordinarily important part of it he
said adding that osha doesn't have to
set foot inside most employers
for a minority of businesses that don't
comply osha could publicize the
consequences they'll issue big fines
they'll issue press releases which will
embarrass some employers while sending a
message to others
so the basic idea here is naming and
shaming
naming and shaming all the people who
refuse to abide okay the goal of that is
not going to be to get people vaccinated
the goal of that is to create an enemies
list for this administration as per
their usual arrangement that enemies
list will now include businesses that
refuse to fire their employees who don't
want to vaccinate
that enemies list includes the domestic
terrorist parents who call out school
boards
that enemies list is anybody basically
who opposes the top-down command and
control
notions pushed by the democratic
establishment here
and then they wonder why the economy is
going south keep pushing guys we'll see
how it works out for you it is a bold
plan indeed
you know if you if you want to stick to
this ideology if you want to stick to
the notion that you are capable of
fixing everything and it's just your
enemies who are in the way
then watch while your enemies multiply
because
that is going to be the predictable
result as well it should be in a free
country alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show that is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
superman gets a little light in the
loafers the italian people chant let's
go a brandon or actually a little bit of
a tougher variation thereof on the
streets of rome and rolling stone
magazine attacks a rock and roll legend
for not blindly going along with
authority check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]